[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hi.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and I'm
here at Google SF for a Tango
workshop.
And with me is Eitan.
Eitan, how are you doing?
EITAN MARDER-EPPSTEIN:
I'm doing great, Timothy.
Thanks for having me here.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: It's always
a pleasure to have you.
For those of you that have
seen Eitan on our show before,
you know that he's a senior
software engineer on Tango.
EITAN MARDER-EPPSTEIN: Yep.
I've been working on
Tango for some time,
trying to help mobile
devices see and understand
the world around them.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: God, it's
such a cool technology.
EITAN MARDER-EPPSTEIN: Yeah,
we're really excited about it.
I know we've talked
about it in the past,
but use cases like shopping
for furniture at home
or using your device
as a tape measure,
or even getting from point A
to B in a mall or in a museum
and using your device
for indoor navigation.
It's really exciting.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah, and
we've talked about those.
We've even shown some screen
capture of those use cases.
I love games on
Tango, and the whole
being able to measure things
is so simple and useful.
And at this workshop you're
going beyond those use cases
and exploring photo and video
and visual communication
with Tango.
Can tell me a little
bit about that?
EITAN MARDER-EPPSTEIN: Yeah.
So at this workshop,
we're really
looking to expand the
capabilities of a camera,
and what people
think of when they
think of their camera
on a mobile phone.
And we're doing this kind
of in three major ways.
So the first one is
in video, doing things
like video stabilization and
rolling shutter compensation.
The second thrust we're
pushing on at this workshop
is around filters
for imagery, so
being able to combine depth
information with the RGB camera
to get really
interesting effects,
sort of stylize your photos.
And the third thrust is really
around storytelling, and just
tying the camera to
the space that it's in,
and enabling new
experiences and new stories
to unfold in front of you
in your actual environment.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
God, that's so cool.
Well, I'll tell you
what, why don't we
actually just look at
some of these use cases
and talk to some developers?
EITAN MARDER-EPPSTEIN:
Yeah, absolutely.
We should do it.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Great.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I'm now sitting here
with Chris and Ana
from the Wall
Street Journal, who
are doing really cool stuff with
Tango at this workshop today.
How are you two doing?
CHRISTOPHER CHESTNUT:
Doing great.
Loving it.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Tell me what
it is that you're working on.
CHRISTOPHER CHESTNUT: Working on
a new angle of photojournalism.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Tell me about that.
What does that look like?
ANA BECKER: We want to create
an app that lets photographers,
as they're taking a
photo, sort of place
in 3D space exactly where
they are and exactly
the viewpoint that they're
shooting through, I guess.
On the users' side,
as they're sort
of navigating their day-to-day
world, footsteps that appear in
places where photographs have
been taken with this app.
It's capability-enabled, so you
can hold your phone up and sort
of line up seamlessly
into your environment
where this photograph was taken.
So utilizing Tango's fine scale
location information and area
mapping as a tool to give people
a new lens to view their world.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's
really exciting.
I think it's really
interesting the ability
to explore space in new
ways because of technology
like this.
And the demo that you
guys are working on
is a really cool
example of that.
I think what I hear
from you is that there's
this gap between
the photographer
as the creator of
the work and the user
who's viewing this work.
And you're trying to
bring them more together.
ANA BECKER: Yeah.
I think that's a really
good way of putting it,
of sort of stepping
literally into the shoes
of another person
at another time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I'm now sitting
here with Andy and Eddie
from Mirada, who are also at
this Tango workshop today.
Tell me what you're working on.
EDDIE OFFERMANN: I sort
of took a left turn
from what I normally am doing.
I decided to sort of approach it
from the perspective of gaming,
and scanning an area and
building an environment
based on what's actually there.
And so my idea
with this was what
if you could just sort of build
the structure of your landscape
with LEGOs or building blocks
or cardboard or whatever
and then, using Tango, scan
that and creates your terrain.
It's basically
taking the mesh data
that we get from Tango
that's great for doing stuff
like just determining
the locations of things
and measurements of things,
or bouncing physics off
of it, but then taking that
data and using it to construct
something that's actually
texturable and looks
like a nice landscape.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
What about yourself?
ANDY COCHRANE: So
it's an app that
takes the depth data from
Tango and then creates
digital art out of it.
Taking that and using the
depth data only from the Tango
to allow you to create digital
art really quickly and easily.
So it's just really,
really fun, really easy
way of taking the depth data
and making something really cool
out of it and then sharing it.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So what do you
think about building for Tango
so far?
EDDIE OFFERMANN: We've
done a lot of stuff
for some other
platforms, and I think
we probably agree that the
functionality is a lot more--
ANDY COCHRANE: It
actually works.
EDDIE OFFERMANN:
It's a lot-- yeah.
It's a lot more mature.
So it's pretty easy
to develop for.
I can kind of rely
on it to provide
the essential
information, and then
I just have to figure
out what I want
to do with that
information on top of it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
OK, Sam, so tell me
what you're working on today.
Sam Maliszewski: I'm working on a video
stabilization app using Tango.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So walk me
through the user experience.
Sam Maliszewski: Yeah.
I mean, I really wanted it
to be as simple as possible,
where you open it up, for
a second you kind of still
see the camera shaking,
and occasionally-- I'm
still-- I'm adding
some new features,
so it's a little bit buggy and
gets some weird distortions,
but after about a
second, it'll stabilize.
And then it'll just be a
smooth image on your thing.
And you basically move the
camera like you would--
it's sort of like having a
virtual gimbal, in a way,
where it's-- it'll--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Like one
of those things that you
attach that makes it smooth.
Sam Maliszewski: Mhm.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Uh-huh.
Sam Maliszewski: Yeah.
It's kind of just a very
little imaginary Steadicam
inside your tablet,
in a way, where
it's just you kind of guide
it where you want to go.
And ideally, it will follow.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's awesome.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I'm now sitting here with
Yuliya and Brian of the New York
Times.
Hello.
BRIAN PLUMMER: Hello.
YULIYA PARSHINA-KOTTAS: Hello.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So you've
been playing with Tango.
What do you think?
BRIAN PLUMMER: We're
really excited,
and there's a lot of
cool possibilities.
And we are in the situation
where we have lots of data
and we're trying to figure
out how we can leverage
AR to showcase this data
and drive user engagement,
and also, I guess,
surfacing our content
so people can discover things.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And what
are some of the things
that users could potentially see
with Tango and New York Times?
YULIYA PARSHINA-KOTTAS:
The one exciting thing
is maybe utilizing some of
the 3D models and the 3D data
that we'd been building.
So imagine seeing that on your
table top, or all around you.
Visualizing some scenes
from the news headlines that
have happened, so going
beyond even the 2D headlines
and jumping into the
3D world around you.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: What do
you think about the Tango
development process so far?
YULIYA PARSHINA-KOTTAS:
I'm actually coming at it
from a different direction.
I am a 3D artist and not
that much of a developer.
So for me, it's been
an amazing experience.
I've jumped into the
Unity side of it,
and even being able to crawl
through-- with baby steps
through getting
the basic tutorials
and actually building stuff
has been really great.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's awesome.
YULIYA PARSHINA-KOTTAS:
So it seems
to be a friendly platform
for even beginners.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Those are some
really cool demos that we just
saw, Eitan.
I can't wait to get
those on a Tango
phone, which begs the question,
when can I get a Tango phone?
EITAN MARDER-EPPSTEIN: Yeah,
so we're super excited.
We're really close to launch.
The first Tango phones are
going to go out this fall.
They'll be made by Lenovo
with a partnership with us.
They're called Phab 2 Pros,
and you can look for them
on store shelves this fall.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's awesome.
And in preparation
for that launch,
you guys have done a bunch
of SDK updates, as well.
EITAN MARDER-EPPSTEIN: Yeah.
So in preparation
for launch, we've
been working hard on the SDK,
both performance improvements
and some new features.
If you're interested in
learning more about it,
you should definitely check
out our developer sites.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
Developers.google.com/tango?
EITAN MARDER-EPPSTEIN:
You got it.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And
we'll put the link below.
I'm Timothy.
This is Eitan.
EITAN MARDER-EPPSTEIN:
Bye, guys.
Thanks.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
See you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]